should we speak in a language before
we're ready that's the subject today it
comes up all the time people are afraid
they're intimidated they know that they
speak with mistakes or with a poor
accent so they don't speak I would like
to buy a hamburger
I would like to buy a rainbow and of
course you know that I'm very much into
input I believe that you can continue to
build yourself up get used to the
language developed comprehension skills
acquire a passive vocabulary all of this
is making you better prepared for
speaking but there comes a point when
you have accumulated a lot of words and
you've done a lot of listening and at
some point you have to jump in and get
wet and this was very much my situation
with Polish uh eight years ago I did
three months of Polish and then I didn't
do anything and two months prior to
going to Poland I spend a lot of time
listening to and reading polish probably
my comprehension ability and certainly
my vocabulary in Polish grew I learned
more new words during this two-month
period than I had forgotten over the
past eight years but probably my
speaking ability was better a years ago
why because I spoke more eight years ago
I had I don't know how many online
sessions during a three-month period
with my polish tutor and typically in
languages where the alphabet is the
Latin alphabet or it's a failure
alphabet
after a month or so six weeks with the
many stories I feel I'm ready to start
to struggle in the language and if I
speak two three times a week you know
the more you speak the better you get as
I always say to speak well you have to
speak a lot so if you look back at my
video that I did eight years ago I don't
speak so bad I mean I don't speak well
but relative to the amount of time I put
in it wasn't all that bad this time
traveling with my wife in Poland
I had the odd semi conversation with a
taxi driver or flight uh attendance on
the airplane on lot coming over not very
successful and then all of a sudden I
was put in a situation where I had gonna
have an interview in Polish and I'm
going to show you this video at the end
of this video you can see me speaking in
Polish and you can also follow a link to
easy polish where the whole the
interview was put up and you will see
comments from people that are mostly
somewhat critical of my polish saying
that it's kind of a mixture of Polish
check Ukrainian and Russian which is
true people saying it Steve doesn't
speak any languages he's always all over
the Internet pretending to be a polyglot
a variety of negative comments others
are encouraging
but the point is I knew going in that I
was not going to speak very well in
Polish however it was still from my
perspective a very positive experience I
actually communicated I mean if you
follow the video it's a bit painful but
throw in some English and various other
Islamic languages I do my best but we
are communicating the person
interviewing me understands what I'm
saying I understand what she's saying
most of the time so there is
communication if I were to do that say
night after night in Poland or
frequently or three times a week online
my speaking ability would improve a lot
because I have this background of
passive vocabulary but the fact that I'm
going to make mistakes the fact that I'm
somewhat yeah I would say intimidated by
the prospect of being interviewed in
Polish when I know I'm not going to do
well didn't prevent me from doing it and
I'm glad I did it so the initial
question is should we speak before we're
ready well well the answer is you're
never ready We are Never As Good in the
language as we would like to be if the
objective is to perform well but if the
objective is to communicate like I'm in
a situation is going to be in Polish we
have to communicate I communicate I grab
whatever I have whatever I can remember
a Polish whatever comes to my mind
that's in a Slavic language I throw in
the odd English word and we communicate
and what I hear from her is pure
relevant High resonance content so that
it's a very good experience so and I'll
leave you the video you can have a look
yourselves and you can send all the
critical comments you want but I don't
mind because even if I spend another six
months working online polish improving
my polish it'll still not be as good as
I would like it to be I think in
language learning we are never quite as
good as we would like to be and yet we
still have to go there and use the
language So my answer is you know should
we speak before we're ready yes because
we're never really ready but we should
nevertheless you know try to prepare as
much as we can focusing on our input
activities so there you have it
speak when you feel like it bye for now
um
foreign
text
transcription
they don't want to look like children
yes yes them Ruth Rosalie okay yeah
um
luji
movies
[Music]
rosumi
I'm happy I'm not I'm not afraid
[Music]
and yesterday
move it
you will forgive me
[Laughter]